NASHVILLE PREDATORS.
FORMER OTTAWA SENATORS GO
SCORE!
THE PASS AC ENOUGH
TIME.
A LMARC
METHOT BEFORE THE GAME TALKING
ABOUT THE POWER-PLAY.
KNOCKED DOWN BY BRANNSTROM.
NOR.
BRANNST
SHOOTS.
ANTON FORSBERG MAKES THEORSBERG.
A LITTLE SNAPSHOT TRIES TO GOSB.
PUT WIDE BY DUCHENE TKACHUK, HIN
THE CAPTAININ
BACK NASHVILLE.
PICKS OFF THAT PASS.
WATSON WALKS RIGHT IN.SS.
STOPPED BY WATSON
BREAK AWAY.
AND THEN KING.
DRIVES IN.
KNOCKS IT BACK.
HEAD UP THE WHOLE WAY AND JOSEPH
IS GOING TO BY TO WHAT A GREAT
DEFENSIVE PLAY BY YOUR NUMBER 1
THE NET ALMOST COLLAPSED ONARIYH
# 5
SAROS AND HE HANGS ON.
>> Jamie: LITTLE PLAY BY JOSH
ON
FORSBERG.
>>.
AT THE PRESENT TIME POKED
BACKHAND CHANCE HERE FOR PARKER
TKACHUK SHIELDSNASHVILLE IS GOIG
TO APPLY SOME PRESSURE FOR THE .
IT'S AN ABSOLUTE BOMB.
JONAS.
RYAN JOHANSEN.
DEFLECTED IN WIDE ON THE BLOCKER
SHOOTS.
JUST TERRIBLE.
WORST FEELING IN THE WORLD AS A.
JOHANSSON CLEANLY BACK TO JOSI.
ROMAN IT BACK.
JOSI PLAYING A LITTLE CATCH.
THISRSBERG LONG SHOT.
ANTON FORSBERG MAKES THE CLOCK.
>> Jamie: IT.
ZUB.